is going to happen i am going to have to
fix you manage you to on a more personal
scale
a a more micro form of management jim
what is that called microgemint boom yes
now jim is going to be the client dwight
you're going to have to sell to him
without being aggressive hostile or
difficult let's go all right fine
[Music]
hello hello this is dwight schrute from
the dunder mifflin paper company well
that's great because i need paper
excellent then you are in luck because
we are having a limited time offer only
on everything wow this is my lucky day
what is your name sir i am bill
butlicker
really that's your real name
how dare you
my family built this country by the way
be respectful dwight please oh yes
michael could you hold on one second
that's my other line what no but i hello
yeah
no i'm just on the phone with this
stupid salesman he's so dumb
probably just gonna keep him on the line
forever and not buy anything
okay it's up to you to change his mind
sorry that was a
family emergency oh no what's wrong you
know what that's private
boundaries dwight come on i'm sorry mr
butler as i was saying
we're having a limited a little bit
louder i'm hard of hearing he's hard if
he's an old man okay as i was saying
right now we are talking louder okay our
prices have never been low you have to
talk louder never been lower louder son
buttocker our prices have never been
lower
that is totally inappropriate
you should never yell at the client now
you listen to me sir here we go the
three words i would describe you as is
aggressive yes hostile and definitely
difficult please mr buy my rate right
give me the please give me a chance give
me the phone mr butt licker give me the
phone i have to put you on with my boss
well i should hope so who is this hello
this is michael scott regional manager
well this is william m buttlicker hello
mr buttlicker how may we help you
michael i like the sound of your voice
you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna buy
one million dollars worth of paper
products today
see how it's done thank you very much
sir i don't think you'll regret it
you are the master there is one
condition michael yes you have to fire
the salesman that treated me so terribly
don't do it michael
it's a million dollar sale
pam would you smell my breath no no let
me smell
good not great yes
full word of advice speaking as a former
baby security in this office park is a
joke last year i came to work with my
spud gun in a duffel bag
i sat at my desk all day with a rifle
that shoots potatoes at 60 pounds per
square inch
can you imagine if i was deranged ryan
cost dunder mifflin hundreds of
thousands of dollars michael ryan david
i don't care if ryan murdered his entire
family he is like a son to me
freak i need a favor
well then you have to call me by my name
gabriel susan lewis what if meredith was
taking her smoking break below that
window you know what would have happened
the shards of glass would have shaved
her face right off and yes it might have
been funny but it also would have been
incredibly tragic so when uh
when did you set up shop i opened this
place after i came back from vietnam oh
vietnam i hear it's lovely
someone complained that the men's room
is whites only
stanley you know that's not true i
didn't say that and why is there a
picture of a white man on the door
well i managed my department and i've
been doing that for several years now
and god i've learned a lot of life
lessons along the way
your department's just you right yes jim
but i am not easy to manage r is among
the most menacing of sounds that's why
they call it murder and not mukduck okay
too many different words coming at me
from too many different sentences i'm
always thinking one step ahead
like a
carpenter
that makes stairs
hey
right back at you [ __ ]
meredith what are you doing i could be
pregnant okay no oh my resolution was to
get more attention
nope she's lying i am a huge woody allen
fan
although i have only seen ants but i'll
tell you something what i respect about
that man is that when he was going
through all of that stuff that came out
in the press
about how ants was just a ripoff of a
bug's life he stayed true
to his films
or at least the film that i saw which
again was ants
thing is
i thought bug's life was better much
better than ants
point is
don't listen to your critics
listen to your fans
uh i get it everybody knows about the
ultimatum yes i told everyone
hey
right back at you [ __ ]
what's your daughter's name again peepee
pipa
people how is she great great
well to be fair
jim
james jimothy
to be fair timothy the
that sounds weird are you okay with
being called jim i am all right
we are not always going to be there
to coddle your heart back
when it disappears to be working
what are you going to do if you're by
yourself and your heart stops
i would die
and you're okay with that i'm okay with
the logic of it no no your partner's got
a lot of attitude but i like that how
long you guys been dating jim couldn't
land me in a thousand years but you're
saying there's a chance shut up
seriously you're gonna send me back
uh yeah that's the safest part of a car
in the event of a crash driver always
protects his side first
battlestar galactica
this is the worst
no question about it i am ready to get
hurt again
ed truck was the manager before me
horrible he hated fun it was like oh ed
truck is walking toward us
why are you the way that you are
honestly every time i try to do
something fun or exciting you make it
not that way
i hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
i love inside jokes
love to be a part of one someday
and you can hug it out [ __ ]
identity theft is not a joke jim
millions of families suffer every year
parkour
corporate needs you to find the
differences between this picture
and this picture
indel has told us there are at least
seven
okay i already see one given
okay
they're the same picture wish i could
but i can't well can but won't
should maybe but
short
jim
james
jimothy
whenever i'm about to do something i
think would an idiot do that and if they
would i do not do that thing
my mind is going a mile an hour and i
feel god in this chili's tonight
you all took a life here today
you did
the life of the party
worst thing about prison was that
was the dementors welcome to the hotel
hell check-in time is now check-out time
is never sorry i annoyed you with my
friendship what is that
it is your birthday period statement of
fact i am beyonce always
i am dead inside
gonna kill myself
wow i'm going to kill myself and it's
your fault
well well well
how the turntables
holly you and i are soup snakes
i am aware of the effect i have on women
depression
isn't that just a fancy word for feeling
bummed out dwight you ignorant [ __ ] do
you think that smoking drugs is cool do
you think that doing alcohol is cool
occasionally i'll hit somebody with my
car
so sue me
oh and you can't get diseases from a
bird where are the turtles
where are they
should i burn this place down when i had
a chance
i'm not superstitious but
i'm i am a little stitious
stanley barack is president
you are black sadly i saved a life
my own
am i a hero
i really can't say but yes
you